hi everyone I am Shree I work at a
company called nil Enzo back in
Bangalore India we're a software
consulting firm mostly due closure been
doing closure for the last five years or
so little lot of a lot of functional
programming in general so this talk is
going to be about my journey and making
machines make music and why I do this is
because it's an intersection of two of
my favourite interests so I sing I've
been doing this for a lot of years and I
do computers so that I feel like this is
a great place for me to do some really
interesting cool stuff this is also all
in the context of South Indian classical
music so a lot of this implies that this
is a recent work and a lot of the
research involved tends to be in the
last five to ten years or so so that's
interesting I've been doing this for
quite a few years and so it's it's a
hobby that's quite a long term thing and
this process involves me rediscovering
things I know intuitively about music
but understanding them from a machines
perspective helps me understand them
deeper and in a different way so that's
something that excites me I'm gonna go
over this in four phases basically and
which is basically a reflection of my
journey through this as well and
fundamentally the theme of the journey
is going to be about bridging the gap
between humans and machines in how we
make music and understand music and
within each phase we'll be doing a cycle
of synthesis generation transcription
modeling and then back and forth so so
that you're not left hanging this is
sort of what some manually transcribed
synthesized music sounds like
[Music]
so right off the bat you know it sounds
quite a bit different this is Indian
classical music and I'll give you a
primer into what all that's about but
before that I want to talk a bit about
how music is universal so across
cultures and across the world in
different continents and from different
races we have fundamentally the same
music concepts so the notion of a tonic
is well understood like everyone knows
when a certain piece of melody comes
back to the tonic right there's a
certain certain resolution pentatonic
scales are prevalent throughout the
world like this West African Chelle Tech
Indian and Chinese music that all have a
prominent major and minor pentatonic
scales and there's this famous Bobby
McFerrin video of him jumping around and
playing the audience if you've seen that
and almost in all cultures is also a
soulfia's you've liked you know during
my first solo si or the Indians are you
come up at the knee and there are seven
notes in a scale in there 12 semitones
in a scale more or less and everyone
across the world kind of understand
understands a lullabye singalong or a
March song or hymn right so this got to
be something to this that holds it
together and and sort of brings everyone
together irrespective of where they're
from and how they've thought about this
so there is a certain mathematical
aspect of this that I want to uncover
right there there are pentatonic scales
they're the circle of fifths and and the
harmonics all that has a lot of
mathematical symmetry to it and there's
the scientific process that we use to
understand melody better but also the
physics of it right
overtones and harmonics and all of that
and of course there's the art where it's
kind melody and music is kind of
inseparable from the person that creates
it and it's about creativity but in the
talk we'll try to unravel
what the mathematical and scientific
aspects of melody are and try to
understand them better so the primary
that I promised so Carnatic music or
Indian South Indian classical music is
what I'm going to be talking about and
I'm gonna appeal to your human self and
kind of let you take this music in
rather than speak a lot about it
[Music]
right so that was a piece of violin
extemporary in a raga called Kalyani but
I think what I'm trying to get to is how
it sounds fundamentally different from
most Western music it's not staccato
there's a continuum continuum of notes
so very briefly the instruments are
primarily a drone called the tampura
where they where we play a tonic and in
v there's a veena that's the you know a
lead instrument it's also strained and
fretted and there's a percussion
instrument called in the Lingam and
here's some visual understanding that I
can give you of an ensemble of Carnatic
music
[Music]
[Applause]
so you see that there's a primary vocal
artist and there's an accompanist that's
an instrumentalist or a violinist there
is a percussionist and there's someone
sitting behind the main artist playing a
drone or the tempura so digging in its
it's classical music and it's art music
in that the focus of you know a concert
is the music itself it's not a part of a
larger festival it's not meant to be a
form of entertainment or something it
the intent is artistic and it's ancient
in that the oldest treatise on this
which is encyclopaedia is it written in
500 BC it's called Marathas not Shastra
so South Indian classical music is at
least 2,500 years old if not more and
there is like every every couple of
centuries or so someone comes by and
writes a huge tree ties in in Sanskrit
about the grammar of music at the time
and so that has evolved into a tradition
called the Lakshmi Grantha and grammar
texts and it's an oral tradition and
that my teacher teaches me something in
class and I listen and I repeat and
that's the primary mode of learning I
don't write things down mostly so in
this age of digitization if you're
familiar with the Gartner hype cycle you
know of innovation and whatnot Kannada
music is it's quite young right which
means that there's a lot of scope for us
doing things in terms of digital
transformation and also presents a lot
of challenges it's also different from
most mystery music in that the nature is
melodic not harmonic Indian classical
music has little if any place for
harmony and it's all about creating
melodic frameworks that help you create
better melodies and sequences of notes
and there are certain concepts called
ragas and camicus which we'll get to in
a bit and very similar to jazz music
it's it's mostly about improvisation a
concert is mostly about improvising in
in pockets around different renditions
and most renditions are covers of songs
from like two three centuries ago
so that's that so entering phase 1 this
is you know me trying to take whatever I
know of my music from my classes and
trying to implement them in software so
I'll try and rush through this a bit
quickly so I can get to the interesting
parts quickly so refunding mental
abstractions we'll go through the tonic
note a note raga and I'll do a demo of
the basics right so first is the notion
of an odd Harish idea or a tonic right
and this is all the notes in Indian
music are relative to this thing right
so there is a notion of a tonic and this
is choice of an artist based on their
voice and their dynamic and like I said
all the notes are relative to this and
it's just modeled as a number right a
MIDI number a swara is a note it refers
to the 12 semitones and who knocked a if
there's a solfege Saregama Bethenny
that's what I say and these form the
elements of a raga but so that it's more
apparent to you if you were to it's just
like an equivalent equivalent of during
my facility right so I say Saregama
Bethenny except every time I say or
every time I say REE it might mean three
different notes depending on the context
and the context is a raga and if I say
ma it can mean one of two things and
when I notate things I write srgm pdn
and so as a model it's very simple they
are just relative numbers from 0 to 11
right and they're all related to the
tonic and this tie isn't as an octave
basically and there's a notion of lower
and higher and higher octave and there's
just a reference of plus and minus 12 a
prescriptive notation is what I write
down in class and what is used to teach
and these are just written as you know
one note per beat generally and so
that's what that is
so from here I want to dive in and give
you an understanding of the notion of
firaga and again I will appeal to your
intuitive nature to understand this
[Music]
doctor
that is it
[Music]
right so what I would appeal to you to
think about is the kind of emotion that
this makes you feel right to me this is
a bit of melancholy a bit of a yearning
right and and that's what a raga is
meant to be it's supposed to be melodic
framework that lets you evoke a certain
emotion or a certain color right and it
is a certain grammar that a composition
must adhere to and as a model what it
has is it has an ascension and a
dissension scale and well the first
thing is that there are a lot of them so
you can see a count is 5,000 or so each
of them has a name and they're
classified so there's a parent raga for
example the first one called Maya
Madhava corner is a parent raga it has a
scale of ascension dissension and it has
a child raga which is Guara which also
has an ascension dissension so quickly
on that the Ascension and dissension can
be asymmetric so for example so that has
five ascension in seven dissension right
and then it can also be say me / Danny /
Marika so for example so they're they're
like cycles there and whatnot right so
they can be asymmetric and nonlinear so
quickly on the demo what we can do now
is look up a certain raga and this is
Indic languages written in Latin script
right so it has to be phonetic so you
search by oh you LA and it has to return
G aually
and so you can play the scale and then
sounds like this
right and then you can play a phrase in
a raga right so right and so for example
this phrase is in the context of a raga
called Kalyani let me give you a better
example right so this is some
prescriptive notation that is played in
the raga called Bella herring
now what I can do is change the context
of raga to another one and this is what
it sounds like right so now this is
actually something that's mind-bendingly
difficult for a human to do right like
take yourself out from one emotion and
like transpose yourself into another one
into another grammar or another scale
but for a machine it's it's stupid
simple right I just want to think about
that with that I think that's mostly
what the basics are and quickly I want
to give you an understanding of why I'm
going into etymology at all so I was I
came across this very recently in that
in in Sanskrit if you're familiar with
that language there is a grammar to
create new words and there is a grammar
that lets you create new combinations of
words or compounds of words and this is
a great elegant solution to the naming
problem in software no more
abbreviations and no more hyphens
prefixes suffixes right you can create
actual new words that mean the same
thing to everyone who reads it so in
that context there's a notion called
shuara right which is a note so swearers
actually SWA da as in swaranjali as when
it shines on its own and and it's called
that because it's resonant so and that
is something that you can hear and and
you can relate to as opposed to me
speaking which is also sound but it's
not resonant and the raga itself means
to die it's derived from the word run
JIT and well it means a color or it can
also mean any motion and so far we've
managed to place and prescriptive
notation but that
sound anything like Carnatic music just
yet right it's still a staccato
rendition so in order to comprehend that
rather than keep all this in our head
and to mellow graphs so what you can do
is take music and look at it visually in
a much more tangible manner you can take
it look at the shape move it around
right so for example here is a phrase
then this is what the machine sounds
like right and that's the graph on the
bottom and if I were to sing this right
so you see these small dips there above
that's not there in the machine at all
so if I were to take a longer phrase
what I sing will have a lot of curves in
it and what the machine has has just
steps right so there's no transition
there's no movement between the notes
like a continuum I spoke of earlier so
that is what Agra Mecca is the
interesting thing is that Agra Mecca is
not something that I understand
in theory learning in class it's
something that I had to dig into to
understand better
so it's an embellishment or
ornamentation take for example
[Music]
[Music]
so that you hear the twists and turns
and then there's a flick and then
there's a hook in the end so that's how
we refer to music in in class anyway and
when we sing it but these are not things
that are easy to notate or have been
notated these are pervasive in in
Carnatic music and every swaram is
thought of as a continuum and turns out
there are actually names for these
things so spiritum for example is the
one with the dip in between guru is the
gradual ascent or descent a compute them
is an oscillation between two notes so
that oscillation is called computer or
ek which is a spiral descent and whatnot
so if I have to dig in and understand
what is really the difference here if I
take a piece of prescriptive notation so
it's like so that is actually Marie pom
but I don't say three syllables I just
say one right so that's the gap that we
need to bridge and there have been some
previous work on it and I have left
links in the references section so I'm
going to move quickly through this so
Gaia is something that has a way to
represent gamma cos through some
notation and there's a database of
phrases so probabilistically it would
pick one gun akka based on a set of
gamma cos given for a raga that's not
scalable obviously because we'd have to
write the phrases ourselves and there's
this work called passerby Sri Kumar
which is basically a frequency envelope
in the lines of you know adsr and other
envelopes so this is pitch attack
sustained-release each of them is a
number and they form a vector and a
single note can be described as a series
of such vectors so basically it's a
mathematical model for describing a
curve or describing a chemical if I
begin to this piece of literature 300
years ago called the sspx Sangeeta
sampradaya presently it has notation for
each of the gamma cos and it has
actually notated a whole bunch of songs
with this and with this what I've tried
was using the notion of frequency
envelopes and modeling something more
generic right so I have
I can model a very easy dip with saying
the frequencies and durations for each
of them and I use a Welsh curve for each
gamma come because that represents
Carnatic music really well and and so I
can use if you look at the right table
there's a notation where I prefix each
sweater with the notation of Agra Makkah
and so this is why it sounds like now
alright and now I have those tips if you
look at the mellah graph you can see
that there are some of those curves and
I was like success know I can make music
that actually sounds like an attic music
I also tried implementing Shri Kumar's
password and this is what that sounds
like so that sounds great and I at this
point I was like hey you know what I can
make the machine make sounds like
Carnatic music and so quickly reflecting
on what we've learned so far
there is a gap which is the prescriptive
notation is insufficient for
reproduction raga is a framework itself
is really powerful and enables the
machine to do a lot more and more than
humans even and melih graphs make
melodies tangible for observation and
gamma car synthesis can be
mathematically modelled as a curve and
the next part was like hey let me make
some music now right let me generate a
stream of infinite music I just want to
sit back in my room and have the Machine
make like you know one hour of music
based on my emotion for the day and
that'd be great right so what I fail to
understand though is what other grammar
exists out there that I can use and to
do that I had to understand or look at
melih graphs of music that's already out
there right and and so I studied that
and I was looking for patterns and I
want to infer the structure or more
grammar to aragón
from the information I saw so a knive
approach to generation would be just
takes forums randomly from errata and
play them with random durations so this
is what that sounds like
right so that sounds like expected
pretty random it sounds like something
it sounds like you know the pentatonic
scale because that's what it's playing
but we can do better than that
so to study the data what I did was I
had to scrape the internet my net
because you know it's not yet digitized
and I had to mine multiple sources and
stitch them together and then create an
interface so that I can look at it in a
meaningful manner and not just keep
doing queries on the database and then I
had the ability to like you know given a
piece of raga give me 50 renditions of
these right and all this code is on
github repository that's open source and
then now I have audio data but I don't
have frequencies and turns out this
problem is actually not that easy to
solve there are some algorithms that
convert musical data or audio data into
frequencies Pratt is one of them what it
does is it does auto correlation and
specialized for a human voice so once I
do this once I pass it to Pratt I have a
mellow graph this one looks dirty and
that's real all the mellah graphs I have
of real music is Mehra graphs of music
from like 4050 years ago and that's what
is still out there and it's not in like
modern music format it's all the music
taken it recorded it as a single track
from the audience so that's like a lot
of dirt there that I have to remove in
all of that but now what I can do is I
can get a histogram of all the
frequencies right of say 50 renditions
of forgiven raga and this is what that
looks like and I was like wow I can see
my raga here and what's interesting is
like the highest peak is the tonic and
there's an octave after that and
somewhere in between there's the fifth
you quickly notice that not all the
swarams have the same all the notes have
the same probabilities or or same
occurrences right and some of them are
blunt some of them are sharp and there
are actually reasons for this in their
melodic reasons for this and if I look
at multiple drag as I can see there
they are different for instruments
they're different for fretted and non
fretted instruments the left bottom one
for example is an example of how dirty
the data can be and well now I have
pictures of grams and this is valuable
data but I need to convert it into
something meaningful
so I convert it into MIDI right just
approximate it to the nearest MIDI but
after doing this even I don't have an
idea of what a note is because it's all
relative to the tonic note and so I have
to find the tonic in turns out this is
not an easy problem either
there is some you know popular work on
this that involves of a lot of digital
signal processing and whatnot and I
figured you know what just pick the
highest one and mostly this works I did
this across hundreds of soundtracks and
literally it was just solved by second
and in pick the highest one and it works
and I have a swarm histogram right so I
have my raga here and it actually he is
what I want you'll notice that the same
swarms across different octaves actually
don't have the same probability and if I
had to look at different raagas even I
have like a pentatonic one and two other
scales and they are all different and so
now if I get back to a generation it's
not so nice so what I can do is you know
create a probability matrix and get the
weight of each forum and and render that
and this is what that sounds like
[Music]
well that sounds better
well it sounds like like the background
music for an 8-bit game you know back in
the day and it doesn't sound anything
like Carnatic music and you see from the
mellah graphs based on random and the
weighted one you can see some
differences in that there's lesser jumps
but it's - quite a lot of jumps right so
what do we learn so far we've learned
that the tonic is prominent of course v
is also prominent and and the the peaks
are sharper right and and they are
higher other note Peaks are blunt which
means that the Continuum's are larger
there and the probabilities are not all
the same and they're not same across
octaves either we can do better right so
what I noticed is one thing the raagas
grammar is not extracted yet as and this
doesn't take into account that the
dissention grammar might be different
from the ascention grammar so I want to
derive with that out and I want to make
it sound more continuous this still
sounds quite staccato and you know
discrete so then more generation what I
could do was given that this is the note
that was played what is the probability
that this was the next note that was
played and I can get this because I have
the sequential data and this is fairly
easy to get and what I could see was
that addition notes probabilities are
higher right so you now know that you
know like Sartori is higher and God saw
Tunis is higher than say an octave shift
and from here it was pretty easy and
closure lets me create lazy sequences so
I actually have a lazy sequence of notes
that I can render awesome and so this is
what that sounds like
[Music]
[Music]
that sounds Pookie I know but for what
is worth the the graph looks way better
and it does have a more continuous feel
to it and it sounds somewhat more
chromatic so there's something this is
aspects of this that I'm actually not
going to talk about but maybe another
day what I had realized by at this point
that I had stumbled onto Markov chains
right so it's the first-order Markov
chains is what I had looked at with this
of course the N thought of Markov chains
so given that these were the five last
notes what's the next one that's going
to be rendered and like God all the
better tools and whatnot and and try to
make better music but I hit a pretty
hard dead end at this point because well
the Markov chains like even higher order
Markov chains didn't actually sound a
whole lot better and I don't know what
to do next but quickly reflecting on
what we did adjacent swarams are more
melodious us and the sequencing Parag
our rules has now been kind of encoded
because you know we have sequencing and
a sentient dissention we have that and
there is a certain gamma car texture
right and sometimes the in-between is is
far worse than the extreme so this
spooky music some would say sounded
worse than the discrete music we had
earlier and that was actually a good
excerpt the tons of really bad ones and
higher order markov chains don't make it
sound better again a dead end I did not
know what to do so I was kind of back to
the drawing board trying to make things
better and some definitions of melody on
the internet always used to say rhythm
all the time and I was thinking whether
I gotta explore that and there's a
repetition of course which is
fundamentally you know psychologically
something that we all really like and
makes music more understandable and
discernable so I want to explore that
and I wanted to generate melodies right
and understand
tonal patterns better so I do a bit into
the literature for this and
turns out it's fairly extensive so
should be Matala beta is something that
I've it's an oft-quoted added so it
means that pitch fit literally pitch
fertility is the mother and temporal
discipline is the father
so liya means temporal discipline or
tempo right and a change in tempo has
communicated wait I think you'd know
this right like if something goes fast
and slow it has a certain emotion to
convey right so this makes me think that
it has something fundamental to do with
the notion of melody right and there's
this other idea from this Sangeeta
ratnakara in written in the 12th century
it says Todd Halle British high Amity as
in Darla is Tala as in base it is again
an etymology where you can feel like wow
I know where this is coming from and so
this is what it could mean right so it's
it's ending on something even far more
fundamental and the latter part of that
says geetam bottom that on rhythm yeah
Holly British system which means that
there's song instrument and dance are
based on Tala right you see how a notion
of rhythm if you can think about it like
that binds together song instrument and
dance it's kind of fundamental to all of
that but it's different from the notion
of rhythm in that it's derived from
poetic meter rather than dance and the
notion of the Torah itself is a
recurrent time frame and it's a cycle of
beats and usually atala is recognized as
hand gestures right so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
and that's like the most popular attala
and it's used for conduction right so if
I'm an artist to have people sitting by
me and looking at me it's it's
equivalent to the Western Orchestra
conduction and then there's an ocean of
Varuna an Avatara is one cycle of beats
kind of analogous to the western bar of
beats but not really that's a closer
approximation and the interesting thing
in in South Indian classical music is
that the number of beats per cycle often
tends to be three five seven
nine and and these are things that even
like a child going to school will learn
all the time
unlike the you know normal four eight
and there are crazy thalles like the
Simeon and Anna tada which has 128 beats
per cycle and there's one called Shara
banana which has a very odd 79 beats per
cycle and there are actual compositions
that exist in this and that are
performed even there are lots of others
you know concepts relating to the notion
of temporal discipline and tarah that
I'm not going to get into I will get
into these three though so a Matta is a
beat very simply that like every time I
beat my hand
that's imatra right and like say eight
matras make an alert now there's a
notion of an ax era Akshara itself means
a shara as in something that cannot be
divided further right so that implies
that it's probably the more fundamental
unit of time that I need to care about
and model right and there's a notion of
a gutty which is actually gate so if I
were to illustrate one two one two one
two three one two three one two three
one two three one two three four one two
three four one two three four so you
know that there is a certain gate and
and this factor that divides each beat
into the sub beat is called the gutti
and turns out this factor is actually
far more important than the Matra or the
Akshara and and so with this newfound
knowledge what I can do now is go and
make my transcription a whole lot better
so earlier when I was doing Markov
chains I will use to consider the 80 BPM
and the 150 BPM song the same way now I
know how I can model that in a better
way I did a very clinical thing wherein
you know just sing the scale up and down
and four different Gotti's I have
different transcriptions so for every
beat I have a certain graph and and
every half beat everyone for every one
eighth beat I have a different graph and
now I can see things what's interesting
here is that at every half a beat there
is a certain structure is there you can
see and this is actually the tonal
structure so if you were to listen to
right so you can hear the notion of
pattern there and the embellishments or
the gum occurs and the ornamentation is
actually visible only at a much lower
end of the spectrum and you'll be able
to hear that here
[Music]
right so you you weren't able to hear
the embellishments but the interesting
thing is that once you've listened to a
lot of this you'll notice that the tonal
structure kind of disappears when you're
listening to this and and so that's what
is really interesting when I dug into
the textbooks I found that the tonal
patterns are actually at the beat level
or rather at the half beat level this is
actually quite analogous to what we saw
with the prescriptive and descriptive
notation back there where humans
actually understood prescriptive
notation but for a machine you had to
give it more detail
similarly we understand a beat but what
we're actually thinking intuitively is
half a beat that's what we can actually
think about but what we need for
conduction is a higher concept and
that's a beat right and so we are able
to see tonal patterns at half the beat
and embellishments or along Terra's is
what Serena River calls it and that's at
the sub beat level and this is really
cool right because I now have names that
I can use for things in software right
like it's that's that's really the
difficult part you have something so
abstract as a sequence of frequencies
right and you want to deconstruct that
into something and use that as a
fundamental abstraction that you build
other things upon and compose them and
having a name for something really makes
that tangible and of course there was a
lot of difficulty in getting here itself
because you know the transcription is
really hard there's a lot of short-lived
frequencies that are less than a half
and up Chara or you know the sub beat so
I remove those remove the non prominent
swarams in raga because you know people
sing in accurately it's not Auto tuned
and then there's the high end low cut
offs because sometimes the
autocorrelation picks up higher
overtones in harmonies you want to
remove that because nobody sings three
octaves higher than the atonic and
they're all these octave shifts
that I found in in the music that I was
generating later on and it turns out
these were actually rests right so
detecting a rest in music when you have
a continuous stream of frequencies is
actually not trivial right you'll have
to look at how the pitch changes and
there's always a continuous drone
playing in the background as well so
that was quite some hard work but then
after this if with this newfound
knowledge of you know temporal
discipline and modeling all this I could
revisit Markov chains because now I have
input with higher quality because I know
that I can use the data at different BPM
s in the same way and I have Markov
chains at multiple levels of granularity
because remember how we have four
different graphs each of them can mean a
different Markov chain so for a single
piece of music I have multiple markov
chains and I have so many knobs and
toggles to play with so for example
there is the order of Markov chain
there's the playback speed and there's
the speed on which the generation is
based and there is the synthesis mode
whether it's discrete or continuous and
there's a speed at which you play it so
if I were to take the generation Gatti
of four where we expect the tonal
structure and then generate based on
Markov chains at that level this is what
that sounds like
[Music]
right so that actually sounds more
melodious and that makes me think that
maybe that is more on them and if I go
lower to a generation gothy of eight and
play that back at a higher speed
[Music]
right so that actually makes me think
that you know that's a tune you know
that I can actually use in a song or use
for improvisation and it doesn't really
sound like Carnatic music just yet it
sure it sounds more Asian but I'm
getting there you know it's it's it's
better but what happens is if you take a
lot of Markov chains and a higher order
Markov chains at the lower level what
you end up getting is a long chain of
just embellishments you can see how
that's possible right because you don't
have tonal structure you only have
embellishment structure and that's what
Markov chains give you and so you end up
generating embellishments after another
so what I thought I could do was take
the Markov chains at the matura level or
the part where I get tonal things tonal
structure and then infuse it with
embellishments and this failed
spectacularly
and this is because it actually depends
on a larger context so a tonal phrase
can be ascending or descending it can be
ascending in the context that when it
goes to the next node it's going to stay
up there for a while or it's going to
move away quickly from there and the
kind of embellishment depends on that
right so you'd have to understand the
patterns at broader and broader levels
in order to understand what the
embellishments embellishments should be
at the lower levels I'm still on that I
don't know how to model that very well
in software but what I did try out was
this notion of repetition right so the
word myrtana is actually derived from
the word everythi which means to repeat
or to recur which is great and this is
like a mind-blowing moment for me
because hey I was searching for a you
know place where I can do repetition an
organic repetition is really hard
because there are all sorts of different
levels at which you can do repetition at
a millisecond microsecond second beat
multiple beats bar free is you know a
line an entire song you can repeat all
of these things and you don't know where
to start and this give me a really nice
place to start and the very simple
notion of repetition takes me to here
[Music]
right so that actually sounds good right
that sounds like a piece of music that
one would use in like in a song
somewhere or like I can even use this
generation to like help me with my own
compositions maybe another day and but
but like I said you know like organic
repetition is hard and trying my hand
out on that insights though time is
fundamental to melody modeling time in
software is something hard we often get
this wrong and this is a quiet part and
parcel of the notion of melody humans
perceive more than a big tree and
hearing a beat machines understand tone
structures at half a beat and
embellishments at lower levels Markov
chains don't work for embellishments and
the simplest form of repetition can be
possible and in this process I also have
quite a few byproducts which is first
thing that identification is a fad which
is that you know within 10 seconds of
somebody playing some music will be like
huh this is that raga and now my machine
can do it too because it's a very simple
you know goodness-of-fit test I have all
this you know database of all the ragas
and I can say given that these are the
frequencies of tones I expect what is
this one and then there's of course the
notion that I can automatically notate
music now so take any piece of audio or
like just sing into my machine and the
machine will give me this forums the
regicide which is really useful in
education drilling and i while i played
while i modeled all the tyler concepts
and I have not Illustrated a lot of them
here I can now have an electronic
percussion instrument I can say what
allowed to play in what speed and it
will just play it back to me that's
really cool but I mean here's a nice
existential conundrum that I often find
myself in which is that you know is
machine music really music because often
times you do understand music or even to
appreciate if you have to get yourself
into the feet of the artist to
understand their expressions and that's
what's meaningful to you you can't
separate the artists from the music a
lot but you have to do that with a
machine and even if a machine comes up
with beautiful music is that still art
so that's something to think about as a
lathe room but for now I'll leave you
with a piece of music that's human and
still better
[Music]
Trini they're putting an egg
[Music]
[Music]
and I have here a list of references
from the find it BCE to to now and
they're all links and I put them up as a
tweet or something so like what Thanks
[Applause]